actor musician millionaire not bad for a  20 year old flick on the TV turn on your  computer Miley Cyrus is everywhere but  it's been a controversial rise to the  top in 2006 aged 12 Miley became a  breakout TV star playing Hannah Montana  the school girl with a secret double  life the show premiered to the largest  audience ever for a Disney Channel show  propelling the girl to international  fame and a number-one hit record go  Hannah Montana by 2007 she was  reportedly earning more than 20 million  dollars a year and that was just the  start in 2009 her single party in the  USA sold more than six million copies  this year Miley's been splashed across  the headlines and is back at the top of  the chart with a new sexed up image her  raunchy performance at this year's MTV  Awards was mentioned in four and a half  million tweets given she's only 20 some  might ask what's left to achieve Jessica  Howard Bloomberg